we begin in Ukraine where the military
says its troops have regained control of
seven Villages two days after President
Vladimir zielinsky confirmed a
counter-offensive against Russia had
begun while fighting is centered around
the russian-controlled city of bakmut
and further south Moscow hasn't
officially acknowledged any Ukrainian
advances but Ukraine says its latest
operation has recaptured villages in the
southeastern zaparita region
what it follows kiev's claims that a
cluster of settlements were retaken
along the front lines in the Donetsk
region where Russian forces have been
entrenched for months on Monday
Ukrainian troops said they liberated the
village of storage from Russian
occupation the recapture of three other
small settlements nearby was announced
on Sunday Russia's defense Ministry says
its forces have repelled Ukrainian
attacks Charles Stratford reports now
from just north of those Villages near
palika navasilka
the town lies in ruins the sounds of
battle echo down these deserted streets
Ukrainian Army pushed out to balika not
the silke in recent days and says it's
recaptured a number of settlements from
Russian forces nearby to the South
there's been a lot of heavy fighting in
this town in recent days the Ukrainian
military tell us that it was Russian
forces that blew this bridge up and
another Bridge
as a means of trying to prevent a
Ukraine in advance we know now that that
has failed Ukrainian forces we
understand
are moving south around two kilometers
from here
this Ukrainian Army video which
algizerakant independently verify
reportedly shows Ukrainian soldiers in
the village of the Rosary
there are abandoned Russian vehicles and
bodies on the streets
at first the enemy resisted tried to
repel our attack with artillery we
managed to take initiative into our
hands and slowly house by house we
started to recapture The Village
approximately we killed 10 enemy
soldiers and took four prisoners
Ukrainian forces say mop-up operations
continue and they're facing barrages of
rocket and artillery fire as they try to
advance
clearing operations are ongoing in this
area they left many surprises many booby
traps everything is mined
paulina's shrapnel scarred house is
still standing
she is the only civilian we find in
velika novasilka
she stayed here throughout the fighting
watching listening to her Town being
destroyed
scratch we came to live for over a year
ago just as the war started it's
impossible to describe everyone has had
something destroyed
oh
[Music]
Ukraine's fight to retake control of its
territory is just beginning
small initial gains may be that months
of battles are expected along Russian
defensive lines that are well prepared
and dug in Charles Strafford Al Jazeera
Nova silke Ukraine
a journalist Yulia shapovalova has more
on what Russia is saying about the
Ukrainian counter-offensive
according to the Russian side the
counter-offensive the Ukrainian
counter-offensive has been going on for
a week and so far the Ukrainian troops
have faced a lot of difficulties uh
we've seen footage of wrecked Ukrainian
tanks and armored vehicles uh this time
around the Ukrainian counter offense it
was on everyone's lips for several
months and it was long anticipated
therefore while the Ukraine Was
preparing its offense the Russian army
Was preparing for defense and they were
digging trenches erecting their
fortifications
strongholds and they were equipping
artillery positions and minefields they
created something which is called LED
defense so it's going to be very hard
for Ukraine to break all the lines of
Defense now particularly when they do
not have proper Aviation while Russia
has intensified its Aviation assaults
plus analysts say that Russia has
managed to accumulate some additional
human reserves the Russian side
continues speaking about
so-called dim Ukrainian perspectives at
the moment